Say hello to the latest graduate of the Mighty
Marvel fitness program.
Kumail Nanjiani recently took to Instagram
to post pics of himself after getting absolutely
shredded for his role in Marvel Studios' upcoming
epic The Eternals, and the entirety of the
internet promptly lost its mind.
Nanjiani now rivals fellow funnyman Chris
Pratt for the most astonishing metamorphosis
to be undergone for a Marvel film.
You'll recall that Pratt, who was best-known
for the role of the rather portly Andy Dwyer
on the classic comedy series Parks and Recreation,
posted a similarly startling photo to Instagram
shortly before the release of 2014's Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Nanjiani, who is probably most recognized
for his role on HBO's Silicon Valley, has
always been a somewhat skinny, gangly type.
Now, he and Pratt have something else in common
besides their roles in Cosmic-based Marvel
films and being hilarious: they both look
like they've been sculpted from freaking marble.
Nanjiani posted a long missive along with
the photos in which, to his credit, he acknowledged
that it's not just anybody who can hit the
gym and pull off such a transformation in
such a seemingly short time.
Nanjiani's caption read, in part,
"I never thought I'd be one of those people
who would post a thirsty shirtless, but I've
worked way too hard for way too long so here
we are.
You either die a hero, or you live long enough
to see yourself become the villain.
I found out a year ago I was going to be in
Marvel's Eternals and decided I wanted to
transform how I looked.
I would not have been able to do this if I
didn't have a full year with the best trainers
and nutritionists paid for by the biggest
studio in the world.
I'm glad I look like this, but I also understand
why I never did before.
It would have been impossible without these
resources and time."
He went on to thank the trainers who, quote,
"made [him] understand true physical pain
for months and months," and deadpanned, "I
think I can almost touch my toes now."
Nanjiani's wife, writer and producer Emily
V. Gordon, responded to a cheeky "congratulations"
comment on Twitter, saying,
"My husband works hard for every role he takes,
but he's worked hard in many new ways for
this one.
I'm so proud of him.
I always have been.
Also, we spent the majority of this past weekend
playing Borderlands 3 so don't think he's
changed too much."
Nanjiani will be taking on one of the more
interesting roles among The Eternals' enormous
ensemble cast: that of Kingo Sunen, who settled
down in Japan centuries ago, isolating himself
from his fellow Eternals and learning the
ways of the samurai.
He typically wields a nigh-unbreakable sword
that can cut through virtually any material,
but this is the only advantage he tends to
deem acceptable.
While he possesses the powers inherent to
all Eternals - flight, super strength, energy
projection, near-immortality - he normally
refuses to use said powers in combat, preferring
to fight in the traditional manner of the
samurai.
In the comics, he uses these skills in the
modern age to become a world-famous movie
star, usually portraying samurai and martial
artists in Japanese action films.
If you ask us, it's this quirk that makes
Nanjiani perfect for the role; you can just
picture him going on about honor and tradition
before donning sunglasses and speeding away
in some ridiculously rare sports car, so as
not to be late for the day's shoot.
We have no doubt that Nanjiani will be a standout
among The Eternals' cast, the largest ensemble
Marvel has ever fielded for a non-team-up
movie.
Obviously, this flick is shaping up to be
a Marvel adventure quite unlike any we've
seen before, and it's sure to impress.
"Do you like movies?"
"Depends on the movie."
"I'm the exact same way."
Owing to the timeless nature of its heroes,
Marvel boss Kevin Feige has said that it may
very well be an epic that spans "tens of thousands
of years."
One thing we can say for sure, however: Kumail
Nanjiani will be looking damn good while cracking
wise and slashing foes to ribbons.
The Eternals hits the big screen on November
6th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.